that DX right What's it telling us it's
telling us like most practically it's
telling us hey which per numeral should
you be looking out for and thinking
about as the thing you're integrating
about right so for example let's just do
this on the side I could give you
something like the integral of a squared
da right which tells you hey pay
attention to the a that a is the
variable that you need to be looking at
you would want to increase power device
so you would get something like a cubed
on three plus my constant right now what
if you saw something like the integral
of a X now if you don't have any other
information you're like is it the a
that's going to increase in power and
divide or is it the X right so that's
why you need extra information to
actually tell you that which is what
this DX and the DX and the DA are
telling you okay so for instance I might
say actually it's the X it's the X I
want you to pay attention to in which
case we just treat the a as if it were
like five or three right okay yeah yeah
so when you're having a look at this
you're like ah we used to put that DX we
used to put it over over here right
right but in some senses it doesn't
matter too much where it is if you're
like if it's somewhere as part of the
the integral but mainly it's telling us
integrate with respect to X pay
attention to the okay all right so yeah
as I trying to hang out there with the
12-man that's where all the action is
really happy so I'll leave the other
example up above if that helps you
what's your instinct to do first what do
you think see you like okay I'm looking
for this and this I expect there's gonna
be some cancelling of some kind okay so
it's good to think right so it's 3x
what's 3 X plus 1 just in around here so
you're suggesting that we oh okay so
you're saying if I put a minus sign out
the is you're trying to factorize oh
you're rearranging it like so yes yeah
okay so you've answered okay yep I'm
fine with that
okay so if we in fact I'll even write
that as my next line so I've still got
that 12 hanging out the top there and
then what you've done is you've put that
the X term you put it out the front
which I'm okay with like it's like
that's the more important thing than
plus-one anyway so so far so good
what kind of deal with that yes yeah
you're right
let me just drop that down before you
lose that thought right I want a
negative 3 it's 12 times
hold on shape do you think which one's
wrong to leave the negative inside or to
leave it no you're asking the right
question right yeah what do we do with
these negatives right so before we come
to negative logs and they use camps and
all that kind of thing let's um let's
take a step back and remember like you
said pattern recognition before right
which i think is exactly the right thing
what we're searching for is this F Dash
and F right F Dash and F now in order to
get the F dash that we want which you
already Tommy is negative 3 there's not
a negative 3 there I have to multiply it
by negative 4 all right like you just
suggested negative 4 times negative 3
this itself is equivalent to the 12 that
I started off with is that okay so
that's the numerator which leaves me
with this on the denominator and I'm
gonna kick this DX out over the side
because I've run out of space on my
numerator how does this help us
[Music]
you have negative three on negative x
plus one use any of three X plus one
yeah yeah yeah yeah then you have the
log hmm okay so good questions right so
the first thing is let's just how do you
how do you in elephant enter one bite at
a time
let's just look at this slowly from the
beginning you've got that negative four
there you wisely factorize that out see
ok well it's it's just hanging out the
front there very good so followed the
pattern and then you're like ah this
thing here that we've got left is that's
the F - to match with this F yes yes yes
it is because the derivative of minus
three X plus one is minus three thumbs
up okay so what that tells us is what we
end up with is the log that you're
saying right so it's the log of this
thing that you've got in here right now
you asked the question before is this a
negative log of I what's going on here
right we're not supposed to be able to
put negative numbers inside logs because
if you were if you had your calculator
and you were like hey what's a log of
negative one it would just say error
unless you unless you start rubbing into
other kinds of numbers right now the
reason why this is okay and this doesn't
cause any problems is because this thing
in here we actually can number one
change the value of x so that what you
end up with is positive that's the first
thing you could do so for example if X
was say zero if X was zero you would get
what you get in here you would get well
in fact humps having trouble growing
myself embrace there we go oh you would
get you would get zero plus one right if
I if I let X equal zero so you get log
of one and that's that's fine you know
you can you can do log of any positive
element that's okay right but even the
case where X is even in the case where
you do get something negative in here
you're okay because there's absolute
value signs okay the answer you value
the value signs kind of save you and
I'll show you why you
we would take the original question 12
on 1-3 x-ray do you remember one of the
main reasons why we care about
integration is because it helps us work
out areas right so if I want to work out
an area under a curve I start to
integrate okay now if you have a look at
this curve that they've given us here it
is it actually does look remarkably like
that sort of you know classic hyperbola
we moved around a little bit but a much
more yeah it's got asymptotes all I can
theme right if you have a look at this
guy right if I were trying to work out
the area under the curve suppose I was
I'm just going to give this guy a name
let's call it f of X equals okay I might
say want to work out hey um can you tell
me the area I'm gonna pick out a spot
here I want to know what this shape
looks like f of X sorry just bear with
me while I put this area in in this
particular domain
let's pick values like say from one to
five now I'm just gonna shift this over
cuz I actually want it Bob see there you
know just bear with me pick some things
up there we go that's the area I work
with okay now if I wanted to evaluate
this area okay
what would the definite integral look
like I've given you yeah one two five
right see you like ah I would form a
definite integral that would look like
this from one the bottom five to the top
from one to five yep started on the top
it's okay I knew you meant and then I
would integrate this thing right now
here's the thing if you put in values
like say x equals one into the answer
because once you integrate you're gonna
get this guy all right you get negative
three plus 1 which is negative two
you've got a negative in there right
you're like whoa that's bad but the
absolute value signs are there to
indicate actually the original
function you came from it exists even
for these values where the log might
look like it's negative so we fix that
by applying these absolute value signs
okay ah but if the whole fact is that if
we were to start with a log function it
only exists on one side but because we
started from this guy over here as you
can see by this graph on the right hand
side yeah it exists on both sides so
therefore we apply the absolute values
to make our integral also exist wherever
the original functioning system is that
make sense okay so um you did pretty all
right with that
I think it will help I think it will
help if you keep on like this this
operation you did here will sort of
become second nature once you've done it
a bunch of times you're like ah I know
exactly what I want amp - one afternoon
off you go okay well let's try something
with a bit more meat on it and then you
can tell me whether you feel comfortable
with these quotient looking edge it was
um all right so let's pick out something
like sorry bear with me while I make a
bit of a choice here well would you like
to bring in ease okay let's let's go for
it so there's these ease in the middle
here so let's let's have a goat seven in
some ways yes I mean they look more
complicated but you're right they're
like I like integrating different
Jenny's because they're simple right yes
it's okay I'll tell you what let's um
we'll push on it a little bit because
like you said if you just have a TX its
derivative is just e to the X which
makes things very very simple but you
can change these Exponential's in in
very small ways that make it more
complicated so let's have a go at seven
H can we try that one
seven H you can see we want to integrate
the expression that's what the question
says right there integrate the
expression okay so I'm gonna write an
integral sign yeah and then H is e to
the minus X oh okay didn't even notice
that
okay that is it is Nikki right so
there's the question now
how do we how do we have a go at this
now just like the earlier questions
right
I want this F dash on F business - on F
that's what I'm working toward yeah is
the integral in that formula and the
answer is no okay because if this is F
let's actually just on the side here
let's write this right if yeah very good
so if f of X is equal to this one plus e
to the minus x on the denominator then F
- like you said that we're actually
seeing chain rule here see you're you're
differentiating that that power up there
you breathe the outside yep and then you
go ah
e to the whatever it just becomes either
whatever right right so I I want a minus
sign to be up there on the top up here I
want there to be a minus sign here but
there isn't however to compensate I'll
just put another minus sign now the
front this long as I've got a pair of
them another yeah yeah no no no it's
it's a it's another one right so let me
just rewind for a second right what I
want is for this to be there well I want
this minus sign okay but you can't just
write a minus sign just because more
convenient to you in the same way that
for this question up here I can't just
write minus 3 at the top here because
it's convenient to me I have to keep it
the same as the original question yeah
so so that's why we factorize that this
negative 4 okay now in this case if I
want to have a minus sign here that's
right that's right so this minus sign
here is going to compensate for that I
do it twice which means I actually
haven't changed it which is a bit like
saying did you remember when we're
talking about fractions in common
denominators before so the reason why
common denominators work is because if I
say all right I want it in terms of 6
it's an awkward word to say because
sixth will be a common denominator I'll
say three sixths plus 2/6 well it
should've chosen different Emma anyway
so the reasons were
is because this is the same as this
exactly and the reason why this works is
because the way I've written it in fact
what I'll do is the negatives cancel
right so I'm just gonna get rid of this
guy here so the reason this works is
because it is in fact equal to the
original question so I haven't changed
anything I just made it look different
to suit my purposes okay which it now
does so let's go ahead and actually do
this now this minus sign that's hanging
out the front here I just write it down
because outside of the integration
process right but now when I look on the
inside it's f dash on F so what I end up
with when I integrate something that
what kind of brackets have C value very
good yep yep perfect flawless that's it
so really in some ways the hard part
here is not the integration it's the
preparation for integrating yeah it's
like I I know a pattern I'm searching
for but doesn't look like that yet so
I'm just going to like twist it a little
bit until it fits the pattern I want and
then off